all a jury has to hear is that claire is
violent and she's doing 25 to life easy
special victims unit is a spin-off of
law and order but um
you know where law and order strictly
stays with
the crime you got the crime
try and find the perpetrator of the
crime bring him to justice
how do the wheels of justice spin with
this criminal this crime
in our show what it is is you'll have
the crime you have the detectives
trying to suss it out trying to figure
it out but at the same time
it's going to be taking the detectives
home how does this crime
infect affect these detectives
don't throw that crap at me elliot you
made a mistake
well one of the things that's so great
about sort of the dick wolf
machine is and one of the things that
he's accomplished on law order and that
we hope to accomplish as well and that i
think we are is that we don't
we don't even though the show is a
hard-hitting show it's dealing with
really tough subject matter
we don't show the crimes we basically
pick up the pieces after we
we get the show at the aftermath and we
find out how did these two people
solve the crime a how does it affect
them personally how does it push their
buttons
was her lack of patience the issue we
had gone down to the
sex crimes division in the new york
police department and these people were
so human and so
not shut off and so present and
empathetic
and available and um i think the worst
part of it is
well for sure is when they have to deal
with crimes with children
that's what really gets them you can go
check oh we will
but right now you're the one who's
looking good for this murder it's not a
show that is gonna say
oh it's a it's a show about sex crimes
come on and watch because it'll be
really titillating and graphic it's
no no this is a very intelligent show of
you have a crime and you think oh this
is harmful this is terrible then all of
a sudden
certain pieces of the puzzle either
start falling or taken away and you got
two detectives going
wait a minute things aren't quite
working out the way you would think
and as an audience member remember
hopefully you'll say you know
it's not black and white it's this is
not right and that's not wrong it's
and you know so it's always it twists
and turns and hooks and
that's where we want to get people in
it's like i think that's why they watch
law order in the first place
it's similar in that way except it's a
much more personal show
that smells good it is good you want
something
i can't copy runs right through me we
just uh uh walked
into the screen test and uh you know
there's marishka
going around doing her hair like this
lies he flips it around
and then we met and there was three
actors and three actors and we got
paired up together
and we walked into the final screen test
laughing hysterically
normally you're like that's my fault we
got the job because you know most people
going good
hi how are you because you know all the
executives are there we're now going to
do one of the scenes
are you ready are you connected she and
i are like
okay
and then what happened was can we give
you a drink